Remember Pebble?
The smartwatch pioneer that had beat all the
tech giants to the punch?
Between 2012 and 2015, Pebble was one of the
most popular smart watch brands out there.
And they had a massive fanbase that supported
them against challengers like Apple and Samsung.
Yet within just 15 months, they went from
being the dominating player to being a large
player to being a laggard to shutting down.
Their entire fall from glory didn’t take
much longer than just a year.
So, what happened to Pebble?
Taking a look back, Pebble wasn’t some sort
of big tech company or some billionaire's
passion project.
Pebble was actually a startup founded by Eric
Migicovsky through Y combinator and Kickstarter.
At Y Combinator, Eric’s smartwatch idea
did catch the attention of a couple of venture
capitalists who invested a total of $375,000.
But though that was a solid amount, it was
nowhere near enough to hire hardware designers,
software engineers, app developers, and everyone
else involved in creating a smartwatch from
scratch.
The problem was that while most investors
were intrigued by the idea, they weren’t
willing to invest into the project because
Pebble was largely a hardware business.
And hardware businesses are notorious for
having razor thin profit margins and large
capital requirements.
Unable to convince more VCs, Eric decided
to take his idea to Kickstarter and this is
where the brand would really take shape.
Tech enthusiasts on Kickstarter had no care
for the business side of Pebble.
They had fantasized about smartwatches for
years, and someone was finally offering to
make it a reality.
Not to mention, Pebble’s offerings were
super cheap especially compared to today’s
standards.
Their retail price was projected to be $150,
but they were offering it for $115 to Kickstarter
backers and $100 for the first 200 backers.
In April of 2012, Eric launched the fundraiser
with a target of $100,000.
He would end up raising the entire amount
within just 2 hours.
And over the next 6 days, Pebble became the
most funded project in Kickstarter’s history
raising over $4.7 million.
By the end of the campaign, Pebble was able
to raise $10.2 million, and with that they
were off to the races.
Pebble began working with a consulting firm
called Dragon Innovation who helped them identify
suitable suppliers and manufacturers.
The next several months were not easy by any
means as Pebble ran into a plethora of manufacturing
difficulties and design limitations.
But, Eric slowly addressed one issue after
another and he was eventually able to launch
the product in early 2013.
The watch was quite simple and nothing fancy,
but what made the pebble watch stick out was
its insane utility.
Pebble supported email, call, and text message
notifications, and you could check stock prices,
track workouts, and monitor your sleep.
It was basically just a standard smart watch,
but in 2013, this was phenomenal.
And the best part was that since Pebble opted
for a minimal energy black and white display,
they were able to offer 7 day battery life.
For $100 to $150, backers were extremely impressed,
and the pebble watch launched to an uproar
of positive reviews and feedback.
Eric didn’t let any of this get to his head
though, he was laser focused on pushing out
more applications and improving the customer
experience.
By February of 2014, the pebble app store
boasted a total of 1000 applications, but
it wasn’t all smooth sailing.
Notable players like Samsung and Motorola
were starting to roll out their own smart
watches, so Eric decided to fire back with
a 2nd generation called the Pebble Time.
Eric had been closely monitoring all of the
constructive feedback he received on the original
Pebble watch, and he addressed basically every
concern with the Pebble Time.
In terms of hardware, the time offered a 64
color display and it sported gorilla glass.
The time also allowed users to swap the stock
straps with third party straps.
Eric also introduced premium versions of the
time called the pebble time steel and the
pebble time round.
The pebble time steel offered higher quality
finishes including steel and leather, and
it offered a 10 day battery life.
Meanwhile, the pebble time round offered a
more traditional looking watch.
In February of 2015, Eric once again went
to Kickstarter to fund this launch, and Pebble
would obliterate every record.
Their goal was to raise $500,000.
They would reach this goal in just 17 minutes,
and they would reach a million dollars within
49 minutes.
By the end of the fundraiser, they raised
a total of $20 million.
Apple would reveal the Apple watch a few months
later, and Pebble fans laughed at it.
Apple expected people to pay $350 up to $17,000
for a product that was comparable to Pebble’s
offerings.
Not to mention, the Apple watch only had a
battery life of 18 hours compared to Pebble’s
7 to 10 day long batteries.
Eric was actually excited for the launch of
the Apple watch.
He anticipated that the Apple watch would
simply increase the interest in smartwatches
and drive up Pebble sales.
And he was absolutely right.
In the 6 months following the release of the
Apple watch, Pebble’s sales doubled.
They even turned down a $740 million acquisition
offer from watchmaker Citizen.
But just 15 months later, the company would
shut down.
So what in the world happened?
Well, I think the first and biggest issue
bringing down pebble was their laser focus
on utility.
From day one, Pebble was never trying to produce
a trendy or lifestyle product.
They were trying to create the most value
packed hardware they could.
They could’ve easily thrown on an LED screen
and cool animations, but they prioritized
battery life over flashy looks.
At first, this was the perfect approach because
the entire smart watch community was filled
with a bunch of tech enthusiasts whose primary
focus was utility.
All they wanted was a long lasting smartwatch
that could display notifications and useful
information.
That’s it.
They weren’t looking to flex their watch
and they couldn’t care less about what others
thought about it.
But as Apple introduced the Apple watch, the
general public got involved, and their expectations
were radically different.
The average person buying an Apple watch doesn’t
actually use it for work related purposes.
They're not tracking stocks throughout the
day and it’s probably been months since
they sent their last email.
The top two reasons that people buy an Apple
watch is for raw convenience and looks.
They don’t want to pull out their phone
to view text messages and they don’t want
their phone shaking around in their pocket
while they’re working out.
Oh yeah, and they like to see the little activity
circles fill up throughout the day.
They don’t care about a 7 day battery life
and they don’t want to look at a bland display.
They want rich colors and an intriguing UI.
And above all, whether they want to admit
it or not, they want a flex.
Apple likes to brand themselves as a lifestyle
brand, but we all know that this just means
that they’re a flex brand.
Now, I can’t really blame these guys cause
I was basically describing myself right there.
But this was really bad news for Pebble.
The smartwatch space was rapidly growing,
but all of the consumers entering the space
weren’t tech enthusiasts.
They were general consumers who didn’t really
care all that much about utility.
But then, why was Pebble’s sales skyrocketing
after the Apple Watch announcement?
Well, I think this was just an impulse reaction
to Apple’s crazy pricing.
Spending $350 to $400 on an Apple watch seemed
ludicrous when there were similar offerings
for less than half the price.
And that brings me into the second reason
behind Pebble’s downfall which is a race
to the bottom.
After the launch of the Apple watch, the number
one thing that still attracted the general
public towards pebble watches was price.
Other than battery life, the Apple watch was
slightly better than pebble’s offerings
in every way.
Now, was it twice as good?
Not even close.
But, it was slightly better and it was tied
into the Apple ecosystem.
This resulted in people buying pebble watches
as a cheaper alternative that offered more
value per dollar.
In other words, the general public wasn’t
buying pebble watches because they were enthusiastic
about the brand or products.
They were simply settling with a pebble watch.
And the worst part was that Pebble was simply
encouraging people to upgrade to an Apple
watch.
As people wore pebble watches, they realized
how convenient a smart watch was, and the
next time they bought a smart watch, many
of them decided to splurge and spring for
an Apple watch.
So, Pebble was almost serving as an entry
level product that got people hooked.
To make things even worse, Apple started to
be more competitive.
IPhone sales had hit a peak in the mid 2010s,
and Apple started taking diversification much
more seriously.
They offered much lower entry prices and they
kept older generations around for much longer.
You can literally get a brand new Apple Watch
series 3 from their official website for $200.
And if you wait for black Friday, you can
easily pick up an Apple Watch for less than
$150.
Now of course, this isn’t the flagship version,
but I’d be willing to bet that most people
would take an older generation Apple Watch
over a newer generation Pebble watch if they
were roughly the same price.
So, as Apple brought out newer generations,
it just became cheaper and cheaper to get
an Apple watch.
And given that price was the only thing that
attracted the general public to Pebble watches,
they left as soon as Apple met that need.
And this was made extremely clear in the holiday
season of 2015.
Up until then, the release of the Apple watch
had been boosting Pebble sales.
But as soon as Apple watches were being offered
for substantial discounts throughout the holiday
season, Pebble sales plummeted.
In the last quarter of 2015, Pebble went from
doubling their sales in the last six months
to negative year over year growth.
And let’s keep in mind, Pebble wasn’t
a profitable business.
They were still in the growth phase and they
needed to achieve economies of scale to produce
sustainable profitability.
If growth was slowing down, they were screwed.
Eric tried to address this decline in demand
with the Pebble 2 which debuted on Kickstarter
in May of 2016.
They still performed extremely well on Kickstarter,
but the excitement was substantially lower
than last time.
Pebble was able to raise $12.7 million and
while that’s an insane amount, that’s
40% less than last time.
And for a startup that needed consistently
increasing demand, this was the end.
Eric scrambled to find a company that could
acquire Pebble, but by this point, Pebble’s
disappointing outlook was pretty clear.
The only company willing to buy Pebble was
Fitbit, and their offer came at just $40 million,
$700 million less than just a year ago.
Fitbit wasn’t looking to save Pebble or
keep the brand alive.
They were simply trying to leverage Pebble’s
software and their team.
So, as soon as Fitbit acquired Pebble, they
fired everyone except for the software team
and shut down the company at the end of 2016.
And that was the end of Pebble.
Honestly, there wasn’t really anything that
Pebble could’ve done better.
Sure, they could’ve tended to the desire
of the general public, but I don’t think
that would’ve played out much better either.
Pebble’s monumental growth was thanks to
a lack of options along with great execution
by Eric.
But the truth is, no level of execution could’ve
overpowered Apple in the mid 2010s.
Truly a sad ending to a spectacular start.
Do you guys own an Apple watch, and if so,
why did you choose Apple over the competition?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you think that Pebble
will always be the OG.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.